لقد هربنا من شمال
غزه ولكننا مازلنا لنشعر
بالامان ايش مالك قوم تخافش قوم يا
[تصفيق]
تخافش ليلا الغارات الجويه تملا سماء خان
يونس مع عدم الاحساس بالوقت تتحول الايام
ليوم واح امشي يا
خليل نمضي وقتنا بمشاهده الغارات
[موسيقى]
الجويه لقد كان هناك الكثير مما لا يمكن
احصاه كان هذا منزل شخص
ما من المحتمل انهم اصبحوا ارقاما اخرى من
الموتى يتطوع الغرباء للبحث عن
اشلائه وبعوده الى منزلنا المؤقت اصبح
الطعام
ناد نحن نطبخ ونشارك كل ما في وسعنا مع
بعضنا
البعض وتعليم الاطفال
ايضا ليتمكنوا من اطعام انفسهم اذا
قتلنا خزانات المياه مليئه بمياه غير
صالحه للشرب
لكننا نحاول الحفاظ على معنويات
[تصفيق]
مرتفعه هناك شعور بالالفه وسط
الفوضى اصبحت الانفجارات اعلى في نهايه
هذا الاسبوع بينما قامت اسرائيل بتوسيع
عمليتها
البريه مما تركنا في حاله من انقطاع
التيار
الكهربائي يا الله
وكانت الهواتف الاسرائيليه هي الوحيده
التي تعمل يستخدم بعض الاطفال اجهزه
محموله للحفاظ على ما تبقى من حياه
طبيعيه لكن كل ما كنت افكر فيه هو ما اذا
كان والدي على قيد الحياه وادعو الله ان
تتمكن عائلتي من قضاء
الليل
[موسيقى]
حتى في منطقه الحرب هناك نور يضيء في
الظلام زوجتي حامل في الشهر
الثالث لسته حنان تماما مثل ابنائنا يتمتع
هذا الطفل بالقدره على تحويل خوفنا الى
فرح
ن